hey guys i'm leanna Galera and I'm here
in defensive once upon a time
what happens when you take classic fairy
tale characters Prince Charming Snow
White the Evil Queen and drop them into
a modern day town amazing possibilities
can happen we have been transported to
so many different lands that you have
not seen anywhere else on TV Neverland
Wonderland all the other lands that you
could go to the core cast on once upon a
time is hands down one of the best
ensemble casts on TV right now I'm not
playing with you and even though I love
the men on the series it is all about
the ladies on once upon a time they show
realistically flawed women but we have
Emma Swan she is our Savior oh did I
mention that she is the daughter of
Prince Charming and snow white yeah how
cool is that her mom's Snow White aka
Mary Margaret is so wonderful we get to
learn all about compassion about a
different type of heroism and what it
takes to have a lot of courage not only
in the Enchanted Forest but also in
today's day and age Regina Mills aka the
Evil Queen is so evil anymore it has
been absolutely phenomenal to watch her
go from that typical Evil Queen that we
see in the stories and realize that she
has a heart she has a backstory we have
Belle yeah I'm talking about Belle from
Beauty and the Beast and she is kick-ass
I don't know if we can say that word but
I just said it and then we have Zelena
aka the Wicked Witch from Oz who has
shown that motherhood comes in all
different shapes and sizes and that the
bond between sisters is probably one of
the strongest out there they have don't
tell the other TV shows the best fandom
of all time
you think I'm kidding no they connect on
Twitter they reach out to each other on
tumblr and as a result this show now has
an even bigger fandom six years in than
it did when it started it's one of the
most viewed shows on Netflix it still
gets crazy ratings and every single time
that we at ET online post something
about it hey it does phenomenal because
their fans cares so much and on once
upon a time they did this way before
Maleficent true love on this show which
can break spells which can save everyone
is not just between a man and
it could be about family love it could
be about friendship once upon a time is
a show about hope the creator's have
said over and over again from the
beginning have hope that you will have
your happily ever after and let's face
it in a world like today where things
are a little bit bleak it's nice to be
able to have a show like this that we
can watch and just let ourselves believe
in hope and believe in the happiness and
true it will rip your heart out at times
I'm not being dramatic we've literally
watched countless times people's hearts
being ripped out but that's the best
part about the show is that you actually
feel something when you watch it what
more can you ask for from a show once
upon a time brings us those little doses
of magic that we all need in today's
world while we wait for our own happily
ever afters hey one sirs what did you
think what is your favorite reason for
tuning into Once Upon a Time
who's your favorite couple who's your
favorite friendship let me know on
Twitter I'm at Liana Galera or leave
your thoughts in the comments below and
hey don't forget to subscribe to e t--'s
youtube channel and i'll see you next
time